South tyrol with its many German
speakers and its capital of boson is a
part of Italy and has been for over a
hundred years this is despite it being
previously owned by both Bavaria and
later Austria it was annexed by Italy
after its victory in the first world war
and has remained a part of it ever since
with the exception of two years during
the second world war some Austrian
politicians as well as those living
there have pushed for the region to be
returned to Austria but this of course
has never happened so why not why is
South tyrol a part of Italy and why did
Italy want it in its German speakers in
the first place so like most questions
surrounding modern European borders this
one can be traced back to Napoleon as of
the late 18th century all of tyrol
belonged to Austria it picked fights
with France and later napoleons France
both of which they lost Napoleon's
winning streak saw him remake much of
Europe in France's revolutionary image
which included giving tyrol to Bavaria
in 1805. this was because Bavaria was a
part of the Confederation of the Rhine a
French puppets date and Friends get
rewards this continued until Napoleon
found a new pet project building in
Italy in the same year the she gave
Bavaria tyrol he oversaw the creation of
the Kingdom of Italy the question was
who was going to rule it after a
rigorous process Napoleon narrowed the
candidate pull down to himself this
along with all the other trademark
Napoleon stuff going on was too much for
his Rivals and so War Napoleon won and
so opted to split tyrol and give itself
to Italy because what was Bavaria going
to do about it as you know Napoleon was
eventually hit with a crippling bout of
defeat and in 1814 Austria regained all
of this it remained a part of Austria
and later Austria-Hungary until the
first world war Italy joined the first
world war on the side of the Anton and
three years and 12 assonos later
Austria-Hungary collapsed and in the
following peace conference Italy pushed
for all of this of which he got this
which included prying South tyrol away
from Austria now the region was
overwhelmingly populated by German
speakers and held little in common with
Italy so why did Italy want it well the
untaunted push for new borders based on
nationality and American President
Woodrow Wilson had pushed for each
region that swapped hands to be given a
referendum the problem was that the
people in South tyrol didn't want to
join Italy and a referendum would have
never succeeded as such better idea just
don't have one until the people who live
there to deal with it so why would Italy
want such a region natural borders
whilst the area didn't have many
Italians it did have lots of mountains
meaning that the north of the country
would be much more defensible in the
future South tyrol formally joined Italy
in 1920 and had much more autonomy than
most other regions of the country this
remained the case until a certain very
nationalist man came to power in Italy
the new Italian government wanted to
squash the Region's autonomy and make it
fully Italian this took a while and
before it could be done a decade later a
Germany angelist Austria and was now in
contact with Italy whose borders now
contained a number of Germans so did
Germany want the territory for itself no
keeping Italy close was seen as much
more important than regaining South
tyrol as such Germany and Italy came to
an agreement the people who lived there
could move to Germany or stay in Italy
and lose their autonomy with many
Germans opting to leave this agreement
became null and void when Italy decided
that the axis wasn't for them anymore
and Germany promptly occupied the region
this occupation would last until
Germany's defeat when the region was
returned to Italy and after the war much
to Austria and Britain's annoyance it
was decided that Italy would retain all
of South tyrol it was given this on the
condition that its people be given even
greater autonomy with Austria as its
guarantor unsurprisingly Austria had
wanted the territory returned Britain
had wanted it divided up like this but
the Soviet Union bluntly refused to
Grant any new territories to Austria
since the USSR considered the Austrian
people partly responsible for the war
and after this it was simply settled
some later agreements increased the
Region's autonomy again and to this day
South tyrol remains a part of Italy
despite its majority german-speaking
populace I hope you enjoyed this episode
and a special thanks to my patrons James
bizonette Kelly moneymaker Sky Chappelle
Corsa wolf Jerry lambden Jordan Longley
Adam Stalter Marcus arsner YN hockey
Spencer Lightfoot rod D Martin words
about books podcast Captain side
augustaf Swan Marvin Castle commune
Winston caywood boogly Wiggly Daniel to
be in Miss is it Aaron the white Corey
Turner the macquapa Alex Schwinn Anthony
Beckett Coppertone Maggie Paskowski she
went in spinning three plates and shot
the first